[Music]
[Music]
oh
hey v you ready
any idea how i can get to hiromi pulled
the blueprint got it all figured out
okay not all but we're good on the
penthouse
best bets to access it from the service
level gotta weigh in from there
all right we going in
let's do this
despite humanitarian efforts nearly 60
people have been killed
have we found heaven on earth permanent
human settlement on antarctica is
celebrating 10
about [ __ ] time as antarctica's first
dollhouse was
recently stay sharp gangs might be
lurking to locals
why does everything here always have to
go to [ __ ]
what then everyone all in position tom
and roxy should already be at clouds
we go on my co-signal they'll mop up
security
you deal with haromi but first you got
to get into the penthouse
okay on my way elevators on the other
side
be safe
how's the stitch you're inside of clouds
who's taking which floor i'll take the
lower level tom will head upstairs
outside of night city the aircraft's
thrusters were deactivated by
sudden emp discharge from a nearby
damaged power station in santo domingo
the emergency landing attempts proved
unsuccessful
the passengers who survived the crash
landing all right
jump down onto the balcony careful
though okay
[Music]
get [ __ ] okay
i know what i said
[Music]
oh
same here i was hoping you'd maybe go to
the surveillance cam in front of the
security room
luckily they're all jacked into virtues
it'd be game over otherwise
right wrong chicks will give you [ __ ] no
matter what you do
this one's a real charmer too
can we get this over with why are there
three guys
what's she playing at
that's our target hiro misato
who are the other two
target audience of today's presentation
he wrote me answers to them directly
now they're going to watch him die in a
pool of his own piss
this is not what we agreed look at me
see this this is a look of unfucking
surprise
i know the claws to them power is a
question of strength
ruthlessness this is the only way
michael
i'm about to jack him out they will not
be chirpy after the rude awakening
one show ends another begins just as
good and unforgettable
understand
all right i'll do what i can jack him
out
well she is no parker wait
what's going on who is this
living proof that hiromi sado's time is
up
this merc has already disturbed the
clientele at clouds once
he murdered oswald forrest and now he's
invaded mr sadow's private residence
as if that were not enough this is where
hiromi's sheer incompetence has led all
of us to
what what the hell i have long looked
upon hiro misato's foolish inept
endeavors
but this i think it's obvious he has
outlived his usefulness
v what the [ __ ] she doing clouds
need new management am i to understand
that this future man come on michael
i think you're getting carried away i
see not all has been agreed
v you got to take him down that's why
we're here bored of all this chatter
i'd rather we just cut to the quick
i'll make
how are you thinking have you any idea
what's gonna happen now
might that be they'll have their revenge
you've turned clouds into a ticking time
bomb
it's not your problem anymore it's just
let it go
and get out maybe i will
but not before i paint the walls with
your blood
[Music]
exits on the lower level of the
apartment then
find the elevator
tom and roxy are outside and safe they
were followed
get down to street level waiting by the
food stalls
you you killed her
oh my [ __ ] god you killed her
wouldn't happen if she hadn't come at me
it wasn't my fault
sorry but i don't buy that could have
found another way
gun owners are reminded that the use of
firearms to advance through traffic
is prohibited by the law
yeah maybe you're right let her get to
me
i'm sorry things ended this way so am i
i uh i gotta process all this in peace
hello i'll be seeing you v see ya judy
you